-You only have a half-hour
when you do your show.
Are there any things that's,
like, left out of your show
that we could help you with here
on our show tonight?
-You know, I've been so busy.
And I've just been
being spread so thin,
I haven't had a chance
to properly thank everyone
I want to thank, and I know on
"The Tonight Show,"
you usually do this
at the end of the week.
But I was hoping that maybe I
could do some thank-you cards
or thank-you notes.
-I mean, we could do --
We can do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I do that? Can I do that?
-You want to sit there?
-Can I sit there?
-Yeah, you can sit --
-Can you sit here?
I'm down. Let's do it.
-You're part of the family now.
You can do it.
You can use the desk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-You can use this.
-Is this a first?
-Yeah, actually, it feels weird
sitting in this.
-Are you nervous?
-I am. I'm totally nervous.
-Don't worry.
I think I know what to do.
James, can I have
some thank-you music, please?
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
You do know what you're doing.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, NBC,
for being the only network
where a woman could have a show
after midnight
that allows her
to keep her clothes on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's exactly right.
-I did my research.
I did my research.
-I don't put the cards
in the envelopes. This is great.
-Thank you, "A Little Late,"
for being a good name
for a late-night talk show and a
great name for a pregnancy test.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah. It's an awful name
actually, yeah.
"A Little Late."
-Thank you, Jimmy and Seth,
for basically being the opening
acts to my show every night.
[ Laughter ]
I don't say this
about a lot of people,
but I've got a feeling
that you guys
are really gonna break through
and make it big some day.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like -- I feel like --
You're almost
too comfortable here.
-Did I do it?
-We cannot wait for your show
to premiere tonight!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a look at "A Little Late
with Lilly Singh."
Take a look at this.
♪ -Hello, my name is Lilly
and I ain't a white man ♪
♪ My skin got some color
and it ain't a spray tan ♪
♪ I know you used to only Jimmys
in the spotlight ♪
♪ But I'm-a throw some melanin
up in your late night ♪
♪ Now, America, this is you
but I'm your late-night host ♪
♪ This used to be a boys club ♪
♪ But I'm knocking down
the doors ♪
♪ It's time to switch it up
in here ♪
♪ 'Cause now a lady
runs the show ♪
♪ I'm 'bout to lead the way for
y'all with my pedicured toe ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm turning off the A/C
and I'm turning up the heat ♪
♪ 'Cause I've been cold at
my 9-to-5 since I was a teen ♪
♪ Only lady in late night,
that's cool but F that ♪
♪ I'm hired to be the only lady
who controls the thermostat ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Lilly Singh, everybody!
"A Little Late with Lilly Singh"
premieres tonight
at 1:35 a.m. on NBC!